so you you mentioned that
at the at the big bang in the early days
um things are pretty homogeneous yes
but uh here we are sitting on earth
to uh hairless apes you could say
with microphones in talking about the
brief history of things you said it's
much harder to describe sweden than it
is um
the universe so there's a lot of
complexity there's a lot of
interesting details here so how does
this complexity come to be do you think
it seems like there's these pockets yeah
we don't know how rare of like
uh where hairless apes just emerge yeah
and then that came from the initial soup
that was homogeneous
was that uh accident well
we understand there we understand in
broad
outlines how it could happen
we certainly don't understand why it
happened exactly and the way it did or
but but uh or you know
there are certainly open questions about
the origins of life and how inevitable
the emergence of intelligence was and
and how that happened
but uh in the very broadest terms
uh the universe early on was
quite homogeneous but not completely
homogeneous
uh there are there were part in 10
000 fluctuations in density
within this primordial plasma
and uh as time goes on
there's an instability which causes
those density contrasts to increase
there's a gravitational instability
where it's denser the gravitational
attractions are stronger
and so that brings in more matter and it
gets even denser
and so on and so on so so there's a
natural
tendency of matter to clump because of
gravitational interactions
and then the equation gets complicated
when you have lots of things
clumping together uh then you know
then then we know what the laws are but
we have to
to a certain extent wave our hands about
what what what happens but
uh the basic understanding of chemistry
says that if things and and the physics
of radiation
tells us that if as things start to
clump together they can radiate
give off some energy so they don't just
they slow down they
as a result they lose energy they
conglomerate together
cool down form things like stars form
things like
planets and so in broad terms
there's no mystery there's that that's
what
the scenario that's what the equations
tell you should happen
but because it's a
uh process involving many many fundament
individual units uh
the the the application of the laws that
govern
individual units to these things is is
very delicate uh you know
computationally very difficult
and more profoundly uh the equations
have this probability of chaos or
sensitivity to initial conditions which
tells you
tiny differences in the initial state
can lead to enormous differences
in the subsequent behavior so so
physics fundamental physics at some
point says
okay chemists biologists this is your
problem
and and uh and then
again in broad terms we know how
uh it's conceivable that that the
humans and things like that can can uh
that how complex structure can emerge
it's a matter of uh having
the right kind of temperature and the
right kind of stuff
so you need you need to be able to make
chemical bonds that are reasonably
stable and
be able to make complex structures and
we're very fortunate that carbon has
this ability to make
backbones and elaborate branchings and
things so you can get complex things
that we call biochemistry
and uh and yet the bonds can be broken a
little bit with the help of
energetic injections from the sun so you
have to have
both the possibility of changing but
also the possible useful degree of
stability
and we know at that very very broad
level
physics can tell you it's conceivable
yeah if you want to know what
actually what what's what what
really happened what really can happen
then you have to work a bit to
go to chemistry if you have if you want
to know what actually happened
then you really have to consult the
fossil record and biologists and so
so uh but but it's it so these
these ways of addressing the issue
are complementary in a sense they but
they uh
they uh uh they use different kinds of
concepts they use different
uh languages and they address different
kinds of questions but
they're they're not inconsistent they're
just
complementary it's kind of interesting
to think about
those early fluctuations as our
earliest ancestors yes that's right so
it's far it's amazing to think that uh
you know this is
the modern answer to the uh
or the modern version of uh
the what the hindu philosophers had that
or tao
if you ask what okay that those those
little quantum fluctuations in the early
universe
are the seeds out of which uh complexity
including uh plausibly humans really
evolve you don't need anything else
you